intensos años de negociaciones concluyan
con estas firmas era el 29 de diciembre
de 1996 y en ciudad de guatemala tras
las puertas del palacio nacional de la
cultura el gobierno daba el último paso
hacia la terminación del conflicto
interno del país junto con la unidad
revolucionaria nacional guatemalteca el
partido que recogía a las antiguas
guerrillas
y venimos para
seguir luchando
de una multitud eufórica se encontraba
en la plaza de la constitución a la
expectativa de que llegara el momento en
el que se proclamará el acuerdo que
acabaría con 36 años de conflicto un
período en el que según la comisión para
el esclarecimiento histórico cerca de
250 mil personas fallecieron durante los
enfrentamientos al mismo tiempo el
acuerdo pretendía acabar con la
desigualdad social económica la
exclusión política de diversas
corrientes e ideologías y la vulneración
de los derechos humanos
muy contentos porque ojalá se acabó y
qué
que la paz sea duradera
25 años después algunos de los acuerdos
están lejos de cumplirse a pesar del
crecimiento económico
47% de la población sigue en la pobreza
las comunidades indígenas continúan
luchando por el reconocimiento y la
violencia política se replicó en una ola
de violencia criminal el país ve un
incremento de los homicidios en este año
de más del 22% en los primeros 5 meses
con respecto a 2020